would like you to show us from the New
Testament where Jesus clearly
>> says that
>> clearly uh shows us that he is the
divine god and not the father.
>> Okay. Now
>> if I show audience to audience yeah
that's excellent because as our brother
said in first century
quote unquote Palestinian Judaism the
term that scholars coined to describe
that period of Jewish history and the
various Jewish beliefs. To them the term
God typically referred to the one they
called father in heaven. Even today when
you talk to a Jehovah witness a Jehovah
witness is taught that Jehovah God is
the father alone. So a Jehovah witness
has been indoctrinated to think Jehovah
is the father. God is the father no one
else. Similarly to the Jews at the time
of Jesus to just use the word God meant
the father in heaven. So the worst thing
Jesus could have done because Jesus our
Lord is the perfect communicator
possessing perfect wisdom because he's
God in the flesh. The worst approach to
demonstrate to the Jews that he's God is
to say, "I am God." Because that would
have confused them into thinking that
he's claiming to be the father in
heaven. So Jesus knowing his audience
better than anyone else because he knows
all men. He knows what's in their heart.
In fact, here let's confirm that. Go to
John chapter 2, read verses 23 to 25.
See what it says? Our Lord on earth in
the flesh, a God man is omnisient still
because he has a divine mind and knows
all things and he knows the hearts of
every man. So in John 2 23-2
specifically verses 24-25, read it for
us if you can.
>> I'll read it this time and then you guys
can read it.
>> Yeah, whoever wants to read. So John
2:es 23-2.
Now when he was in Jerusalem at the
Passover Passover feast, many believed
in his name when they saw the signs that
he was doing. But Jesus on his part did
not entrust himself to them because he
knew all people
>> and needed no one to bear witness about
man. For he himself knew that he was in
man.
>> He knew what was in man. Yes, sir. So
right there, Jesus knows his creatures
better than anyone because he created
them and knows their thoughts. So to
that audience, Jesus claimed to be God
in such a way where he made sure they
didn't think he was claiming to be the
father but the father son who's equal to
him in essence and nature and they got
it. That's why you'll find throughout
the gospels not just they see that he's
a man who claims to be God but he's not
the father and they think he's
blaspheing. So just give you one
particular example of that. Go to John
chapter 10 and read 27 to30. Whoever
wants to read it. Would
>> someone like to read it?
>> I don't know who's listening, but
hopefully you're out there.
>> Yeah. And look it up also as you if
you're watching John 10. Look at those
verses that Brother Sammy said.
>> 27-30.
>> John 10 27-30.
>> All right. I got this. My sheep hear my
voice and I know them and they follow
me. I give them eternal life and they
will never perish.
>> Now, if you pause right there for a
second, unpack what our Lord said. He
said, "They're my sheep. They are my
sheep. They hear my voice
and I give them everlasting life and no
one can deliver them out of my hand.
Right? No one can deliver them out of my
hand. They hear my voice. They're my
sheep. So they're the flock in my hand
under my care. Before you read 28 to 30,
I I'm sorry, 29 to30. I want people
understand that for a Jew who knows
their Hebrew Bible right there, Jesus
claimed to be God Almighty. He said,
"Believers are my sheep. They're in my
hand, the sheep in my hand under my care
and protection and I give them
everlasting life. How does that show
that Jesus is claiming to be God
Almighty? Well, if you guys can, whoever
wants to turn to Psalm 95 and read 6
to8. Psalm 95 6 to8
whoever who's going to turn there, I
don't know.
>> Someone want to read it?
>> Read it or you want me to read it
>> before? If you have it. Yeah, if you
have it before.
>> So, here we go. John uh Psalm chapter 95
6-8.
Oh come, let us worship and bow down.
Let us kneel before the Lord our maker.
For he is our God and we are the people
of his pasture and the sheep of his
hand.
>> Did you catch it?
>> Yep.
>> They are my sheep in my hand. Old
Testament says God's people are the
sheep of his hand. And then whose voice
are they supposed to hear?
>> Lord,
>> we'll read.
>> Yeah, Lord. You could have
>> You didn't read that part.
>> Oh, okay. Uh, today if you hear his
voice, do not harden your hearts as
atba.
>> Mebba.
>> As on the day at Masa in the wilderness.
>> So, whose voice are they supposed to
hear?
>> Lord.
>> And they are sheep of his hand. Right?
>> But Jesus says they hear my voice. They
are my sheep in my hand. And then he
says, no one can deliver them out of my
hand. Right? Since you're in Psalm, go
to Isaiah 43:13.
Isaiah 43:13. If somebody else wants to
do it,
>> yeah, whoever gets there wants to read
it, go ahead. Isaiah 43:13.
>> From eternity to eternity, I am God. No
one can snatch anyone out of my hand. No
one can undo what I have done.
>> You saw that no one can snatch out of
God's hand, right? But Jesus, no one can
deliver out of my hand or pluck them out
of my hand. Now go to Deuteronomy 32:39.
Deuteronomy 32:39. Was that ESV, by the
way?
>> Yes.
>> Oh, it was okay. I was just curious.
Yeah, because it says it. It captured
the meaning of the Hebrew. It says uh
>> NLT
>> from the NLT. NLT, New Living
Translation. All right.
>> In Deuteronomy 32:39. Yeah, we got so
many Bibles. We're all It's like, yeah,
confusion here, but it's okay.
Deuteronomy 32:39. Watch. Anyone who
knew the Old Testament like the Jews did
would know Jesus just took the very
language of Jehovah Yahweh and applied
it to himself. Even though they were
looking at a Jewish man and they thought
it was blasphemy. So in Deuteronomy
32:39, what does it say?
>> Anybody
>> see now that I even I am he and there's
no God beside me. I kill and I make
alive. I wound and I heal and there's
none that can deliver out of my hand.
>> There's that language again. Not only
does Yahweh say none can deliver out of
my hand, both good for good or for
calamity. Meaning if God wants to bring
judgment on you, no one can stop him. If
God wants to preserve you, no one can
stop him. He also says, I make alive.
But Jesus says, I give everlasting life.
So Jesus gives all believers that kind
of life. That's moral incorruptibility
because he's going to transform us to be
morally incorruptible where we will
never be able to sin again and make us
physically immortal which means that
Jesus must be all powerful, all present
and all knowing because he must know who
the sheep are and have the ability to
pres preserve them incorruptibly.
Therefore, anyone knowing the Old
Testament clearly sees Jesus just
claimed the very language of Yahweh God.
But at the same time, he's not the
father. Because if you go to John 10:29,
look what he says there. John 10:29-30.
>> So what we read the the continuation?
>> Yes.
>> My father who has given them to me is
greater than all and no one is able no
one is able to snatch them out of the
father's.
>> So he's not the father, right? Cuz he
says my father. So they got it. Okay.
You're not the father in heaven. Okay,
we got it. And no one can snatch out of
the father's hand. No one can snatch out
of your hand. And then he says John
10:30,
>> I and the father are one.
>> See, most Christians will take John
10:30 and think that in itself is
sufficient to show that Jesus claimed to
be God. No, that's not sufficient. You
have to read 27 to 29 to see what kind
of unity Jesus is referring to. I and
the father are one in our ability and
power to preserve believers immortal and
indestructible. Something no creature
can claim because no creature is
almighty except God. So the Jews got it
because in 31 it says at this they
picked up stones to stone him. Right?
John 10:31. And then in 32 he says Jesus
said to them, "Many good works I've
shown you from the father. For which of
these do you stone me?" And here's the
key. 33. Look at the key what the answer
is. The Jews said, "For a good work we
do not stone you, but for blasphemy. And
because you, a man, make yourself out to
be God." See, they got it. You're a man
and you claim to be God even though
you're not the father. But they didn't
believe it because they thought he's
just the man no more, no less. So the
way Jesus expressed his deity, they got
it. No one doubted that this man is
claiming to be God and yet he's not the
father. But they didn't believe it
because they couldn't envision number
one, God becoming a man and number two
that there is a son even though they
should have known this from the Hebrew
Bible that is equal to the father and
yet he's not a separate God. So that's
how I would deal or that's how Jesus
dealt with Jews. And I would have to
follow a similar approach with Jehovah's
Witnesses because Jehovah's Witnesses
too get confused when you say Jesus is
God cuz to them they're going to say,
"Wait, if Jesus is God, did he send
himself? Is he his own son? Is he his
own father?" Cuz to them, God means the
father. So this is one way of
approaching the topic depending on your
audience. So that was Jewish Jesus's
audience. Any other people you want?
Because if I can go any approach.